hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the psychologist
Lawrence Kohlberg and a number of
different papers and books set out a
theory of human moral development a very
comprehensive theory that distinguishes
six stages and this is often brought up
in the context of ethics in part because
we can associate certain moral theories
or ethical perspectives with these
different stages and there's a sort of
valorisation it's it's not good for a
person to remain down here where they do
indeed have to start the ideal is for
them to advance all the way up to level
six Kohlberg himself in point of fact
does not think that that happens in the
case of most people with in most
cultures and institutions but he is
setting this out as a sort of blueprint
for how a person would become a
progressively better and better human
being and all of this has to do not just
with what they would do as a matter of
fact he points out that a person might
be able to carry out moral reasoning
without being able to necessarily
fulfill what that moral reasoning
requires and that's
for an issue rather it sits in terms of
the ways in which we think out the
situation's dilemmas problems issues
that we encounter and what we bring to
bear what values we have what what
strategies what things we consider to be
relevant or important in making moral
decisions and one last thing before we
look at each of these stages in turn
Kohlberg believes that not only can you
find these across cultures a person
cannot skip stages now they could be
forced into a situation or institution
where they're supposed to behave and
recognize a higher stage and they might
actually be able to function for a
little while
in that context but in general in order
to develop you have to start at stage
one you can't skip that all the way up
to stage five you have to go into stage
two or level two and then go to the next
level three four five and all the way up
to the top you cannot jump through the
the ladder so to speak there's no way of
shortcutting the process and it happens
through not only maturation but also
through moral conflicts and having to
think these things out and reflecting on
one's own experiences which are quite
often experiences of failure so all that
said let's talk about these six stages
now and Kohlberg associates them into
three groups we have what he calls a
preconventional level or stage which
includes number one and number two then
we have a conventional one where social
conventions the mores of the society or
culture group or even perhaps even
family if we're talking about isolated
individuals becomes very important and
that includes three and four and then we
have a post conventional which doesn't
mean that convention
are entirely left behind but they are
placed into a larger context in which
conventions make sense in terms of and
in how they contribute to something that
goes beyond something that transcends
mere conventions so stage one and I'm
taking this from moral development a
review of the theory stage one he said
he calls us the punishment and obedience
orientation a person who is at this
stage focuses primarily on the physical
and perhaps to some degree emotional
consequences of action
those determine the goodness or badness
of an action so if an action gets me
punished it's a bad action if the
punishment if it action gets me rewarded
it is a good action or it could be good
if it doesn't involve any sort of
punishment that I'm taking he says that
this this is looked at this way
regardless of the human meaning or value
of those consequences so all those are
put aside for somebody who's at level
one he goes on to say that avoidance of
punishment unquestioning deference to
power are valued in their own right not
in terms of anything else and he
specifies that at the level four there's
also this respect for authority but
that's very different than what's
happening at level one and level one you
respect authority because they can
punish you and level four there's a more
abstract recognition that Authority
itself is good in some way not just
because they can punish you
some people will remain at level one
their entire life most people Kohlberg
thinks are able to move on to level two
or stage 2 what he calls the
instrumental relativist orientation and
here we're looking at things through the
lens of what's good for me so it's very
egoistic and in terms of what's
instrumentally good for me what's
instrumentally good becomes good what's
instrumentally bad what stands
the way of my desires becomes bad and I
start to take other people into
consideration I start to think about
their needs but primarily just insofar
as they have to do with my needs so he
gives the example of saying I'll scratch
your back if you scratch mine it's not
quite the same thing as a recognition of
reciprocity that's more just saying this
is a useful strategy for both of us to
get what we want and there's no value of
the other person as such in an
orientation along these these sorts of
lines so he says human relations are
viewed in terms like that of the
marketplace today we might call that a
transactional way of looking at things
that's a very common term that's being
used today for ethics transactional
ethics somebody who's got transactional
ethics pretty low level of moral
development then we move into the
conventional levels and here there's
kind of a interesting leap that takes
place so he says at this level
maintaining expectations of the
individuals family group or nation
becomes perceived as valuable in its own
right prior to that it was just listen I
want to you know get the stuff I want or
I just want to avoid being punished so
I'll say the party line now the person
actually starts to believe it and they
start to use that in their moral
reasoning so the attitude is not only
one of conformity to personal
expectations and social order but of
loyalty to it valuing it actively
maintaining supporting and justifying
the order and he says there's two stages
involved here the lower stage is what
he's got a couple names for this
interpersonal concordance or you know
harmony with other people right and he
calls this the good boy or a nice girl
orientation good behavior is what that
which pleases or helps others and is
approved by them there's he says there's
much conformity to stereotypical images
of what is majora
or natural behavior behaviors judged by
intention saying a person means well
becomes important for the first time and
you win approval by being nice to other
people by satisfying the social
conventions which now are come you know
to be valued in their own right so a
people-pleaser is at this level and we
might think that certain ethics could
also be at this level if your ethics is
primarily based on how you make other
people feel an ethics of sympathy for
example then that would probably be at
level three at level four Kohlberg
thinks we have a higher stage of
development because now we're starting
to grasp abstract things no longer
within the matrix of relationships but
for their their own sake for the first
time as things that are valuable in
their own sake so he says because it's
the law & order' orientation he says
there's an orientation towards Authority
fixed rules the maintenance of the
social order right behavior consists of
doing one's duty showing respect for
authority and maintaining the given
social order following the rules not
breaking them maybe even going beyond
that and thinking about what the rules
really require of you so you can be
conscientious and here there's kind of
an interesting bifurcation it's its
rules but it's also the person who
happens to be in charge you might say
well what if there's a conflict there
well then you've got a level 4 issue
going on right now by moving past the
the preconventional and conventional
levels we start to get into the realm of
where Kohlberg thinks real human moral
development is taking place many people
do manage to get into the the social
convention phase level 3 and level 4 but
not too many people actually make it to
5 and 60 things so at this level there's
an effort to define moral values and
principles that have a lid
apart from the authority or emotional
tenor of groups things that are more
Universal things that are more abstract
things that you could say are part of
the civilization rather than just part
of a culture so he calls the first one a
social contract legalistic orientation
and he says generally with utilitarian
overtones what does that mean to have
utilitarian overtones it means that you
think about how things affect the
community as a whole and you look at
decisions in a rather flexible way
saying we want to maximize the good
outcomes and minimize the bad outcomes
that means that some people in fact may
have some bad outcomes imposed on them
but we only do that for the sake of
maximizing the total good that is going
to be produced and very often this will
be framed in terms of respecting
individual rights or people having
individual rights norms agreed to by the
society rather than norms that just
happen to be their right norms that a
reasonable person could come up with
that's why it's a social contract theory
there is as I pointed out that
utilitarian overtone to it he says
there's a clear awareness of the
relativism of personal values and
opinions and a corresponding emphasis on
rules for reaching consensus it's no
longer just rules that you have to obey
because the rules it's now the rules
themselves serve a purpose in allowing
us to work out our problems with each
other they become procedural rules as
opposed to substantive rules at level
six which usually in in Kohlberg's
theory he did theorized about a level
seven in a few places level six is
usually viewed as the pinnacle of his
theory causes the universal ethical
principle orientation he tells us that
right is defined by the decision of
conscience in accord with notice this
this key idea self chose
and ethical principles appealing to
logical comprehensiveness universality
and consistency so that's quite a
mouthful
think about what that actually means
Universal ethical principles that are
chosen by the person this cannot be a
frivolous or arbitrary choice because
the universal ethical principles that
are chosen do have to themselves meet
these standards logical
comprehensiveness universality
consistency they have to cover all the
cases they have to be consistent with
each other so you can't just pick
principles willy-nilly
for example Kohlberg would not say that
the marquis de sade and the characters
that he places his philosophy in the
mouth of in his novels is a level six
guy because he's you know got these
Universal ethical principles he does
actually have Universal ethical
principles but they're not really
ethical principles that would be
logically consistent and could be
applied across the board instead what
are some examples he he says the Golden
Rule the categorical imperative Conchi
and morality for example which would fit
in there he says they're not concrete
rules like the Ten Commandments at heart
these are universal principles of
justice reciprocity and equality of
human beings and respect for the dignity
of human beings as individual persons so
you see there's quite a difference
between this and everything that's going
on at a lower level and the person has
to be able to choose these principles
for themselves
so for Kohlberg there is a full
development of the human being and going
from level 1 all the way up to level 6
or even to level 5 that's pretty good in
his book there are some criticisms that
have been made of the theory but it is
quite an interesting stage development
model and as I pointed out how do you
move from from you know place to place
within this through experiences through
talking with others through
failures and reflecting on those through
conflicts and eventually through
changing what it is that you value and
how you think about moral
decision-making
you